previously on TV since your area of
study is physics experimental physics
[Music]
full disclosure I know the twist I can't
unnoticed you only to be surprised and
react in the moment but also want me to
know everything about every goddamn
world out there morning Mike how's it
hanging this varies irks me maybe in the
1920s it was fun to ask your friend how
he's swinging and balls were flinging
but here in the 2020s the proper
response is get a forking life you sure
[ __ ] but also the demons have sex damn
it you putting ideas of demon porn in my
head and then not following through and
what is up with this desk
they have Janet's style constructs that
can create anything in a magical matrix
but they're real after lives our desk
jobs and antiquated office gear you know
a show has a low budget when they break
out the adding machines instead of like
fancy 65-inch monitors and LED lights
and what does the date oh oh in mean you
don't know print is long enough already
great awesome so what's in the bulb is
it just the outside is it Souls is it
marshmallow flop is it marshmallow fluff
made from souls I have to know and this
show won't for can't tell me I don't
care which two of you go you can decide
you have 30 minutes wasting our precious
time by starting off the current episode
with the last scene from the previous
episode cliche awesome what is up with
that coffee table the end of that thing
is sawed off like a weapon that was
Jason I'd accidentally speared himself
in the nut section of his tracksuit yet
it's piece of consequentialism the
morality of inaction is solely judged on
its consequences so if my sins videos
bring you joy why am i adding positivity
to the world rather than trolling
everyone with my snarky commentary you
mostly fell asleep in class or made fart
noises with your hands truely's also
this does poke all kinds of holes in a
Michaels plant why even throw in these
little pleasures when the overall
purpose is to torture these four doesn't
do anything except make the place more
palatable regardless of how they
interact I mean I get the sense Jason
could do this all day and be happy I was
dropped into a cave and you were my
flashlight
lighten the darkness is super important
especially in a cave but also rope what
a chibi were a harness and rope to help
lift her out of the cave rather than a
limited lights
that will die when the batteries run out
sexy skyscraper I think the rock already
handled the sexy skyscraper bed and 2018
rather well and yeah this is 2017 but
they should have smelled what the rock
was cookin no matter what they decide I
bet you're gonna be in pretty hot water
with your boss but based on what we find
out shortly Shawn is if not his only
bonus at least one of them and they are
having this conversation by themselves
with no one else to hear so who is this
conversation for I get that demons would
take human form around other humans but
why would they here they're all just
hanging out with each other in the
demonic version of the office finish
finola regular antimatter spine you know
sometimes a clever show decides to be
too clever like a velociraptor
disguising itself as clarice starling
only [ __ ] write this well wastes
precious time to make sure all the
curves and lines look perfect [ __ ]
take it from me write horribly and get
out there to enjoy life this should have
been the biggest clue that Michael was a
horrible demon man all ah yes the fart
leaker model from Ikea designed to allow
your chains to conveniently fall just
out of reach and your ass trumpets to
redirect downward to make it more
distinguished bellow I love you and I
think you love me we can be together the
show has done many many good things so
far but manufacturing this Chiti
triangle or quadrangle i guess is not
one of them man yeah yeah real Eleanor
is actually a fake Eleanor named Vicky
but it doesn't make the storyline into
us stupid you realize the bad place is
not some sort of couples retreat right
it is Jenna and I would like to go
oh yes Jan is still here there are over
300 people in the good place you're
telling me that not one of them has
called for Janet to help them with
something this entire time I'm calling
[ __ ]
also why is Janet not she should be
reminding Jason that she just said it
was literally impossible for her to go
to the bad place so Judy and I are gonna
go to the bad place
what trust me about this because why
would I share my plan with you before
calling Michael and Sean out even though
I still had plenty of time to do that
Michael I just found an obscure
precedent in the rules that might just
save everyone but Jon don't need it but
wouldn't it be interesting to live in
this not so bad good place forever if it
means avoiding actual hell
Eleanor figured it all out so I used
that to her advantage and played the
system you know had this not been
spoiled for me I would have loved this
twist this laughs I still remember the
echoes across the
it's fear about the shocking reveal for
the good place because this show can
firmly grip our attention and deliver a
surprise I am all for returning us in
housecats
just me being here forced GD into an
ethical cluster fork oh come on if this
isn't a good place lift the curse ban
I'll show you how to do it I love you
and I think we should stay here and try
moment I just rehearsed that speech for
like three hours
but Eleanor just told GD they were going
to sacrifice themselves a few minutes
ago this entire scripted bad place
players only works if behind the scenes
these characters are given prompts and
then allowed to improv for people
perfectly suited to make each other
miserable they could've at least tried
to get more natural looking pictures I'm
pretty sure the shots of Gd and Jason
are from an episode they couldn't
actually have been in yet since this is
pre bad place good place she Hannigan's
also on calling shenanigans on this
entire plot twist miserable these four
have been irksome at best to each other
and sometimes quite pleasant hell you
may as well have called this the
bothersome place or the slightly
annoying place this isn't even as bad as
in Melrose Place or Peyton Place I think
that we can get them to torture each
other for a thousand years I think you'd
be lucky to get six months out of this
insane gambit but why Shawn is
hilariously specific about his under a
bet
but he doesn't know anything about the
plan itself this is just like a
six-year-old yelling at his buddy that
just said oh huh
sorry I thought we reserved the
conference er no Tod we haven't until
three more about conference balcony but
get the [ __ ] out of here Todd hello
dingus you hurt everyone in your life
with your rigidity and your
indecisiveness it was at this very
moment my wife paused the show and
slowly turned toward me with a look that
read did you get that even though she
has a point
I won't change Arabia what no probably
not aha rich fraud with legs for days
side note I might legit be in tootanny
come on you there with the Ellen or what
yeah I'm gonna erase your memories you
know make a few changes then start over
again
villain expose its plan before an acting
able plan cliche I don't care if Michael
eventually becomes a protagonist he's a
straight-up [ __ ] this season
just tinker a little try again
okay this works you can't eat anything
right correct
open up is because this face isn't
suspicious in the least you know the way
you feel when you see a chimpanzee and a
baby tiger who become friends perplexed
filled with anxiety reminded a circle of
life and our mortality that's how you're
going to feel every day fork if you're
going to leave yourself a note for a
scenario such as this why wouldn't you
have at least a little more information
on it maybe also this is how watch the
door for a few minutes and don't let
anyone in without the password morning
Mike how's it hanging how's Danny Phil
yeah you apparently didn't put one of
the new cover sheets on your TPS reports
oh yeah I'm sorry about that I I forgot
try to do a good job good job this is
the bad place this was supposed to be my
big moment I just rehearsed that speech
for like three hours Marsha Marsha
Marsha and you can all set
[Music]
[Applause]